okay
i can't
uh
um
um
hello
louisiana and mississippi they always
get
a couple days and they get it much worse
than we do obviously
i'm like why did you send the rest of
the way up here
yes
did you send that email
you like the new uh
amy sent you i think she said some kind
of code or something i forgot to do that
so you need to do that
the worst part
um
all right that was the same thing yeah
for next week
rebellion
which one walk up
this morning
our
three four numbers missing
points we have three people out here
there's only three
well i'm done with it
but i is a job
i can help you with that dude yeah
you're here
did you see miller just tweeted
that they noticed a trump trip sunday
georgia
faa i mean so that's where he's going on
sunday
um
is
okay
i know
uh i was just told yesterday that is
oh
i'm not sure how many
particularly
you know
uh
you have several
is
i know this
no i skipped it
um
oh
okay
oh
oh
huh
i'm smiling
foreign
oh
hmm
i think
they always go the wrong direction
uh
good morning everyone here we are
five days before the election
our focus has been so largely on
stopping and crushing the coronavirus
in terms of the election five days from
now
we are confident we are calm
and we are prepared we are ready
we're ready to address the coronavirus
in a way
that is based on science
crushes the virus and addresses
the impact on the lives the livelihood
and the life of our democracy we are at
a fork in the road
the path we have been on has taken us to
a place where we are approaching nine
million infections
a path to 250 000 people who have died
a path that has taken us uh to tens of
millions of people on
unemployment eight million people
falling into poverty 17 million children
food
insecure again 23 members
a million workers on unemployment
and the situation will worsen if we do
not
change our path the heroes act has
offered
a path science-based
well-funded that
honors our heroes crushes the virus
and puts money in the pockets of the
american people
i just recently last night or this
morning
this morning sent a letter to secretary
mnuchin
uh spelling out some of the concerns we
are still
waiting to hear back from the
administration
in good faith i believe both sides have
gone to the table
to discuss the priorities two weeks ago
the secretary said that he was willing
to accept our
testing language you just wanted to make
a light touch
on the language two weeks ago the light
touch was 55
of the language largely eliminating our
initiatives that addressed
uh the disparities of the virus when it
came to
uh minority communities in our country
more people in the minority community i
am told have died of the virus
than those not in the minority community
i've said it before
if you're a black child you have
five times more chance of going to the
hospital for covet
than if you're a white child if you're
hispanic eight times more chance
it's sinful it's sinful that we have not
addressed protecting the lives of the
american people
on the path that this president has
taken starting is calling it a hoax
saying it's going to magically disappear
the list goes on
and even though in all of our
legislation we have talked about
testing as being a key
to stopping the spread of the virus so
the letter is self-explanatory it talks
about state and local government
what is it this statement that it was
even in the wall street journal
that said uh that local um state and
locals
uh face the biggest
cash crime crisis
state and local governments face the
biggest cash
crisis since the great depression
and yet the president mocks and says
this is unnecessary for us to do
satan local government fiscal soundness
is
very important to our economy
not only that we want to honor our
heroes they're out there they're
fighting health care workers
first responders police and fire
sanitation
transportation food workers our teachers
our teachers our teachers
and the president says it's a matter of
pride
that he not support them then we have
safe schools we should be most of the
schools in our country could be
open actually if we would take the
scientific approach
it takes money it takes more money
of than they are willing to put up and
we're asking
for their response in that regard
to have more space therefore more
teachers
ventilation sanitation
technology to enable our children to
actually attend school children learning
parents earning the parents can go to
work
in the absence of that we also want them
to put more money
for child care if the children are not
going to school
the parents cannot go to work unless we
have more funding
for child care and they just will only
go so far
and that's what we're asking them to go
farther again
8 million families as the cares
benefits fade away 8 million people
more people on have fallen into poverty
there's a way out of that child tax
credit
earned income tax credit these are
working poor people
falling into poverty and yet
the number they gave us back was zero
they admitted that zero is not a number
even though they said they get back with
a number
they don't hesitate to give 150 billion
dollars
in tax credit to in a tax advantage
to the wealthiest people in our country
and yet
they yet they refuse to help families
from falling in poverty and by the way
all of this is stimulus for the economy
even if you don't care about people as
there's some question as to whether they
do
you should understand that it is
stimulus to the economies people
spend this money immediately inject
demand into the economy create
jobs and that is what has helped
the economy even in this third quarter
but now that front that money is fading
unemployment insurance we
uh we're still waiting for some of the
response to the five million
americans who are exhausting their
benefits osha and liability
uh safety in the workplace for us is not
a subject
it's not a provision it's not an item it
is a value
it is an ethic workers will be safe
in the workplace especially in the time
of a pandemic
where their exposure to it uh could not
only make them
sick but also also their
uh their families if they bring that
home
so we're we think that you know we we
have
a list of concerns just give us your
answer
then you can weigh the equities if we
don't like this or we like that or
whatever it is
and come to a conclusion
but we are ready i feel very confident
that joe biden will be elected president
on tuesday
whatever the end count is
but on the election that occurs on
tuesday he will be elected on january
20th he will be
inaugurated president of the united
states
so while we don't want to be
overconfident or assume anything
we have to be ready for how we are going
to go down
a different path we've come to a fork in
the road
when it comes to the corona virus the
president has taken us on a deadly path
the heroes act takes us on a scientific
path
to help save the lives the livelihood
and the lives of the american people so
it's interesting to see how many people
are turning out
voting in advance uh it's a real
what whoever they're voting for it's a
joy to behold
people exercising their civic duty
honoring the sacred right that we have
to vote in our democracy it is appalling
to see the obstacles to participation
that the republicans and the presidents
are putting in the way
we complain when other governments try
to
undermine the integrity of our elections
or the credibility of our elections
that's one country and another
credibility or integrity of our
elections
but is appalling when the president of
the united states
contributes to that uh placing doubt
onto the credibility of our elections
and to have a president who says he
might not he may not
accept the peaceful transfer of power
all the more reason for us to thank god
for the courage of these people going
out there to vote waiting
hours in line because the republicans
refuse to put money
in this uh any of the legislation that
we have had
to the extent necessary to make sure
that when people vote
there's ample space uh there's examples
to facilitate it's a discourtesy the
american people to say
you go stand in line for hours
we can do something about it but your
time
is not worth anything to us
so again this weekend she'll be very
interesting to see how many more people
will vote
in advance i hope that people will not
depend on the mail because they have
done
all they can to dismantle uh the postal
system but i salute
our postal workers our letter carriers
and those who are
making the best of the situation but
even uh
the postal service is saying it's too
late now to mail
a first class piece of mail to take more
than five or six days to
reach its destination is uh that speaks
for itself
so here we are and it is a it's a
remarkable remarkable
experience that our country has been
through
hundreds of thousands of people dying
millions infected joblessness
raging
poverty rates going up 17 million
children food
insecure and just
just to say something about women in
september alone nearly one million
people
when women one million one million women
left the workplace one million women
left the workplace
and what's the president's message to
women
we're getting your husbands back to work
well factually it isn't even true but in
addition to that what
decade is he living in what century is
he living in
so completely removed from the realities
of life
and that has caused death without any
questions you may have
figured yes thank you thank you come on
thank you
thank you very much you said you're
confident in
joe biden on tuesday here i want to kind
of ask you to look into the future a
little bit on coronavirus with other
issues that could come up here you
always talk about your caucus and the
beauty and the nicks here there's a lot
of
diverse opinions that's right do you
think though that that could be
a problem whether it be on a virus or
some of these other legislative
initiatives
of environment voting rights download
our caucus has a beautiful array of
thinking of generational
gender gender id ethnic background
geographic
differences in the rest but the one
thing
that unites us is our commitment to
america's working families
and that means our children their health
their education the economic security
of their families a clean safe
environment including gun safety
in which they can thrive in a world at
peace in which they
can reach their fulfillment so again
we don't any of us want to lead or
represent
a caucus that is lockstep
lockstep caucus we invite the
exuberances the differences of opinion
and we do not see that as a problem we
see that
as an invigoration yes ma'am
speaker um the economy grew at an annual
rate of 33.1
in the third quarter does president
trump deserve any credit for that
the cares act deserves credit for that
uh the uh
we had lost ground in the second quarter
uh this barely makes up for that and the
cares
act uh deserves credit for injecting the
resources
into the economy whether it's then in
our subsequent cares and the subsequent
ppp
so it's as if somebody used an example
this morning as if you lost a hundred
dollars in the second quarter and now
you're making up
uh 65 glory alleluia
no and and if we don't pass a a
recovery bill a uh a um
kobus a cobot 19
bill that that we will face
dire circumstances as well so yes
congress and and the administration work
together in a bipartisan way to pass
the cares act as well as subsequent
legislation to inject
resources into the economy the lack of
doing that this time
is going to take us back down to another
path
yes sir thank you madam speaker if you
are correct that joe biden is going to
be elected
you're still going to confront a balance
of power with president trump and a
republican senate for the lame duck
would that not argue for you to take a
somewhat smaller bill that the system
can produce in the lame duck
and then get the rest when biden is
president this is not a
of small we're not talking size we're
talking quality
and we we are not going to take a small
bill
that has the bulk of reinforcing funds
the richest people in america
while questioning the integrity of
people on unemployment insurance
so we'll have we will well i want i want
a bill
for two reasons first and foremost the
american people
need help they need real help
and second of all we have plenty of work
to do in the joe biden administration
we're going to build the infrastructure
of america in a green way
we're going to make sure health care is
available to all americans lower the
cost of prescription drugs
we're going to have hr1 one right off
the bat be about
uh cleaner government so that we can
reduce the role of big
dark special interest money it prevents
us from having
uh policies that the american people
need
and uh and are have doubts that we can
do unless we reduce the role of big dark
money
and we've have a number of bills that we
have passed
uh that we'll be ready for of course
this will be impacted by
uh joe biden agenda his build america
better
is similar to our moving america forward
but nonetheless
uh we'll be working in uh between the
white house and the congress to get
those jobs done so we want to we want to
have as clean as slate as possible going
into january
we will have to do more on the
coronavirus to make sure that the
vaccine god willing uh will be available
and that
will take resources to make sure it's
available to everyone not just those
in a position to pay for it so yeah no
we what we've been why would we be
talking to them if we didn't want
a bill uh other than our
our heroes act 3.4 billion which is what
they make trillion which the american
people need
they say you need to show more
flexibility to anything like mitch
mcconnell has
people are hungry people on the verge of
eviction
people need money in their pockets we
have
enormous challenges there they don't
believe in governance
they don't like the public role in
helping people
and they don't believe in science so
they
ignore the recommendations of science
for masking
for testing tracing treatment separation
ventilation sanitation
we are in a terrible place and it was a
decision
with a decision made by this president
of the united states
so we have to have enough money to
address that and we still haven't gotten
the yes from the white house on that
subject
so again has to be about the quality of
what it is yet it's not just something
to say
we surrender they surrender to the virus
we're not surrendering to you
yes sir do you how do you think about
the uh increasing corporate taxes
given the state of the economy in a in a
first couple months of the biden if
there is a violent presidency in the
first couple months well why don't we
wait until we win the election
uh we have our transition and the
president of the united states puts
forth
uh his agenda i always have thought that
when we do
uh a major tax policy we should try to
do it in his most bipartisan way
possible contrary to the dark of nights
of speed of light uh passage of a bill
that gave
83 percent of the benefits to the top
one percent
in our country and then they reinforced
that
in the uh cares and the cares act uh in
the dark of night as well
uh so it's not a question of having that
discussion here
i think there's a large uh quite an
agreement that we should have brought
down the corporate rate
but we should not have given away the
store uh at the expense of america's
working families
okay that's it thank you all very much
thank you as a giant fan what do you
think about the dodgers winning the
world too can you avoid that
california you know while i
die
because it just takes your mind away you
forget your differences with other
people
it's just like the arts it's just
therapeutic
in that it not only entertains
what i like about sports it's about
numbers
and i'm all about numbers there's
elections
on the floor and but sadly the numbers
in this case because this president's
failures are so staggering and sad
and that it compels for this imperative
that we act
on a different path from where the
president has taken
for the children thank you
that's right